blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman well my friends they did it this
shouldn't even be notable this shouldn't
be newsworthy this shouldn't be a story
but 35 republicans
joined democrats in the house of
representatives
to vote to pass a bill that would
set up this bipartisan 911 style
commission to investigate the donald
trump
january 6th insurrection riot
and um it is incredible that it is
only 35 members from the republican
party
that joined 176 republicans
uh or one no 175 170 175
175 republicans the vote was 252 to 175
saying uh we don't want to know what
happened and we don't want
all of these remaining questions
answered in terms of the motivations and
the genesis
and the explanation of why did it take
so long to get a bolstered police
presence and the military all of these
different things that should be
investigated
they don't want to know or they
believe that it would point back to them
in some way this is the greatest
motivation for these republicans
not wanting this investigation which is
that many
of them know that it would not look good
for them but we will get back to that
axios is reporting
as i told you yesterday house minority
leader kevin mccarthy
opposed this commission and it looked
like there would be between
20 and 50 republicans who would vote in
favor of it
and 35 did this makes it more
difficult for senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell
to just dismiss it all as partisan
because you did have 35
republicans in the house who were in
favor of it now as i told you yesterday
the setup is really as bipartisan as you
can get
democrats control the house yes so there
is going to be
some more control that democrats have
rather than republicans over the
commission
but it would be a 10-member commission
five members selected by democrats
five members selected by republicans the
chair
would be a democrat because democrats
control the house and the vice chair
would be a republican
and if they are going to issue subpoenas
uh which presumably they would
every subpoena has to be signed off on
by the chair
and the vice chair so there are
republicans i mean listen if i'm kevin
mccarthy
and i realize that i was on the phone
with trump on the day of the
insurrection
and the content of that conversation
may be of interest to the committee and
i might be subpoenaed
um that is going to be something that
would require both
the democratic chair and the republican
vice chair
and indeed there seems to be at least
somewhat of an appetite from republicans
to figure out what happened and so if
you're kevin mccarthy
and you're thinking i might have to
testify here
or at least documents related to my
conversation with trump might be part of
this
it makes sense you would try to make
this go away so the next step here now
that the house has passed it
uh the senate majority leader chuck
schumer democrat from new york
has said the bill will get a vote it's
not clear whether any
republicans in the senate are going to
get on board
two days ago mitch mcconnell said he
can't support it in its then current
form
two sources say that it's conceivable
that mitch mcconnell will have to change
his tune because of these 35 republicans
who voted in favor of it
10 republican senators would be
necessary for this to pass you cannot
pass this in the senate with
50 plus kamala harris as the
tie-breaking vote
that would be the budget reconciliation
process it cannot be used here so in
order for this commission to happen for
it to be voted through in the senate
you will need all 50 democrats and 10
republicans or
49 democrats and 11 republicans or you
can do the math any combination that
gets you to 60.
this could have started months ago there
was no interest before
joe biden was president there was not
even the possibility before joe biden
was president because democrats
didn't didn't control the senate um and
now hopefully we are getting closer to
that it could have been done a long time
ago it really could and it's because of
republicans and republicans only
that it has not yet happened so we're
going to follow it
um and there are any number of different
reasons why different republicans would
want
this not to take place but
i would say i am more confident than
i've been in the last
two weeks today that ultimately this is
going to happen
and let's now look at some of the uh
i don't even really want to call them
reasons because they barely even have
anything to do
with the actual commission and the riots
but let's look at some of the words
that came out of the mouths of
republicans during yesterday's debate
about this
on the floor of the house okay so to
reset
fortunately the bill to establish
a commission to investigate
the riots of january 6th known
colloquially as the trump riots
passed the house of representatives
yesterday with the vote of
democrats and 35 republicans
but the path to that vote was very
circuitous
and it included a bunch of completely
unhinged and off-topic
rants and raves from a variety of
republican members of the house
starting with trumpian radical
congresswoman
marjorie taylor green of i harass aoc
for a living fame
now if there is anyone who is
incentivized
not to have january 6th investigated it
would be marjorie taylor green
because she is likely a perpetrator both
in
ginning people up to want to riot by
telling lies about the election for
months starting in november of 2020
and also because she had close
associates rioting
a guy who called her a great friend and
who worked with her on other
quote issues participated in the riots
so here is marjorie taylor green listen
to this
as a person that was a victim of the
january
6 capital attack i can tell you i'm
against the violence that happened that
day
but i do not believe a january 6
commission will achieve
any resolution because we have already
had our department of justice
arrest 445 people with 100 more to be
arrested
soon there's also reports of people
being held for 23 hours in solitary
confinement
that is that should not be happening
these people even haven't even had a
court date yet
you see what's going to happen with the
january 6 commission is the media is
going to use this
to smear trump's supporters and
president trump for the next few years
and cover up the damage the real damage
that's happening to this
to the people of this country which is
tearing down our economy ripping our
borders wide open
and hurting this country the real
damage of the riots was done by trump
supporters
she's acting like it would be unfair
like it wouldn't make
sense for the investigation to end up
making trump supporters look bad
the rioters were all trump supporters
she says listen
400 people have already been arrested
100 more people are going to be arrested
this entire thing is going to be misused
to make trump supporters look bad well
the 500 people you just mentioned are
trump supporters
these are sort of the facts marjorie and
the facts may lead us to say
hey hundreds of these trump supporters
were really bad people
or at least they made bad decisions on
that day then madison cawthorne
another trumpian lunatic comes to the
microphone
and says this entire investigative
commission thing it's all bogus
because my constituents in south
carolina mind you
not a border state care mostly about the
border
here is madison cothorn mr speaker
according to
according to recent data from my
district the number one concern of my
constituents
is the biden border crisis let me repeat
that
the number one concern of my
constituents in north carolina
is the crisis at our southern border
over 1
600 miles away so there's a lot to talk
about there
first if it's true that his south
carolinian constituents care mostly
about the border
and not about the riots it's partially
because
he and his fellow republicans and fox
news and newsmax
have convinced people that there was a
crisis at the border when in reality
very little has changed from when donald
trump was president and in fact
we now have relatively few kids at the
border
second whether there is or is not a
crisis at the border and no matter how
it ranks for his south carolinian
constituents
you can deal with whatever's going on at
the border and have a commission
investigate january 6th
both things can be done it's not we
shouldn't do this
because in south carolina in my district
people care about the border
you could do both then republican
congressman dan bishop goes into the
semantics game where he says
this was a riot it was a mob but an
insurrection no no no
it's about insurrection let me just say
this if it was an
insurrection it was the worst example of
an insurrection in the history of
mankind it was a riot
it was a mob and it was significant
and it was troublesome but this is not
bipartisanship
and i fear that the gentleman from new
york may find that he has been played
now this one keeps being repeated it
wasn't
really an insurrection because they
didn't succeed
first of all you can still investigate
what happened
whether or not you define it as an
insurrection or an insurrection attempt
the failures of leadership the failures
of of law enforcement
potentially by design of those around
donald trump but
you can investigate all of that stuff
and it's worthy of investigation whether
or not you deem it an
insurrection but remember just because
it didn't succeed doesn't mean it wasn't
an insurrection if you try to bribe
someone and they refuse the bribe you're
still
able to be charged for bribing someone
uh and
so so that is just a terrible semantic
game that they are playing and many of
them are playing it
speaking of semantic games then
republican congressman louie gohmert
spoke
remember this guy is a former judge if
you can believe that and i actually
don't even know what he's talking about
which is really common with louis gomer
see i challenge you to figure out what
he's talking about
look things have changed a lot since the
911 commission
because back then we did not have a
problem on both sides either side of the
aisle condemning anti-semitic remarks
now
one side has a problem doing that back
then
we didn't have uh we had never in the
history of congress had one party
commit what could is arguably a felony
up to 20 years in prison
by preventing an ongoing session of
congress the exact charge
15 12 18 usc that is being
alleged against people that came in as a
judge
i would have no problem sentencing
anybody that broke into the capital
anything that committed a crime here
but let's be real the partisanship
has been dramatic and that's why
it's different now than the 911
commission let's get back to being
bipartisan
and not use every tool as a partisan
stick
to beat republicans with i really want
to know what on earth louis gohmert is
talking about i just don't understand it
and that's really common with louis
gomer where
it's not that you hear one of his
arguments and you say oh here are the
three reasons why the argument makes no
sense
i just don't even know what he's saying
i don't know what he's talking about
and then lastly from republicans for
today
new republican conference chair elise
stefanik who remember
recently replaced the canceled liz
cheney
she somehow ends up talking about joe
biden
destroying the economy in the last four
months
even though the topic of debate is
supposed to be the riots not the economy
and not joe biden
thank you americans across this country
are facing crisis after crisis
just think in just over a year ago in
early 2020
our economy was booming our standing in
the world
was strong we had just rebuilt our
nation's military
and our communities and families were
thriving
here we are a little over one year later
in just
over 100 days president biden and
speaker pelosi
have dismantled that foundation and the
american people
are paying the price americans are
suffering
all lies i mean just all provable
demonstrable lies the military wasn't
rebuilt by trump
because it was fine when donald trump
took over trump tells that story of the
the generals came to me they said sir
we're out of bullets
all made up the military was fine um
we were seen as a joke around the world
for electing trump we are now recovering
our reputation globally but again none
of it has anything to do with the
insurrectious riots
and then lastly overall making a lot of
sense
our friend congressman tim ryan
democratic congressman from ohio
has been a guest on this program really
good guy he just had enough of the
nonsense and he made that clear
i want to thank the gentleman from new
york and the other republicans who are
supporting this and thank them for their
bipartisanship to the other 90 percent
of our friends on the other side of the
aisle
holy cow incoherence
no idea what you're talking about
benghazi you guys chased the former
secretary of state all over
the country spent millions of dollars we
have people
scaling the capital hitting the capitol
police with lead pipes across the head
and we can't get bipartisanship what
else has to happen in this country
cops this is a slap in the face to every
rank and file cop
in the united states if we're going to
take on china
if we're going to rebuild the country if
we're going to reverse climate change
we need two political parties in this
country that are both living in reality
and you ain't one of them i yield back
the bible so listen at the end of the
day
republicans did what we expected them to
do and they are incentivized to try to
shut this thing down because
what the riot uh commission might
uncover is that they themselves are very
much to blame what took place on january
6th and then at the end of the day they
did pass the bill
to start this commission we will now see
what happens in the senate
let me know what you think about what is
the fundamental reason
that republicans don't want the
commission is it because
they think it will make them look bad is
it because it will incriminate them
something else all of the above let me
know your thoughts
and remember that if you have been
thinking of becoming a david pakman show
member
monday memorial day it's going to be a
perfect day i can feel it the weather
will just be beautiful
we are doing a one-day membership
special we are looking to drop
a massive bomb of new memberships and we
are going to offer them at a huge
discount
if you want to be notified about how to
take advantage of that discount just get
on my newsletter
at davidpakman.com quick break
really great program today we might keep
this one
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite
apps lets you do it's called blinkist
and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
there is no need to wait today is a
great day to get yourself a david pakman
show membership the number one
funding source for our show sign up at
joinpakman.com
also want to invite you to participate
in the david pakman show
subreddit discussions you can find that
at davidpakman.com
slash reddit more than 30 000 of our
viewers and listeners
have already subscribed a couple of
posts i want to
briefly discuss that i spotted on the
subreddit this morning
one user uh said backlash
to new mask recommendations show why the
left
are bad at politics arguing the cdc
changed mass guidelines to say
you can wear them indoors and there has
been surprisingly a lot of backlash to
this
from our own side let me be straight
this is a huge political win for joe
biden his agenda is back to normal
and the quicker we get back to normal
the better he looks and in terms
dems and the left as a whole if he were
a republican president
every single republican would be
shouting through the roof stops of the
success of this
and how we are basically out of the
pandemic instead our own side seems to
be actively hampering our political
agenda
by questioning the science of the
decision and some cities and states are
keeping mass mandates
in effect regardless of the science so i
think that this is a really really good
point and i'm going to do a commentary
later
where i'm going to talk about the the
mask forever stuff um
i i won't preempt that because i'm going
to get into it i think this is a really
astute commentary
which is uh some of the reaction when
the cdc said
vaccinated people don't really have to
wear masks anywhere because the vaccines
are so effective and the spread is cut
so dramatically and the risk is just so
low
a better reaction would be it's
incredible how quickly joe biden got us
to this point
the left could have united and made this
unilaterally
a win for joe biden look biden did covet
stimulus
and he asked people to wear masks for
100 days and all this different stuff
and vaccination
and now look at what the cdc is able to
say unfortunately i think that some on
the left misplayed it by saying this is
crazy even though we've been following
the cdc all along
we're going to keep mask mandates we're
going to do all this different stuff
that frames it as not the win that it
really should be considered and this is
a separate question from whether
individuals
could should or might choose to keep
wearing masks personally
which i think is perfectly fine and i'm
going to address later i think that's a
very astute commentary about a missed
opportunity by the left excellent post
also a number of posts including this
one about joe rogan's comments
that quote straight white men are being
silenced by quote
woke culture i did a big rant about this
yesterday during a live stream where i
talked about
the um the predecessors to so-called
woke culture which is not a term i use
but it's sort of a
a follow-on of michel foucault's
postmodernist
analysis of literature which has turned
into
critical theory and a bunch of other
things which lead us to
every narrative every narrative has to
be equally valued when i really don't
think that that's a good idea
and there are some extremes which maybe
joe rogan is alluding to but big picture
joe rogan's comments about woke culture
and uh people aren't going to be able to
go outside anymore because in the past
some have been imprisoned and straight
white men won't be able to speak
it goes cartoonishly too far i ranted
about it for almost 15 minutes yesterday
on a live stream we might pull that and
make it a standalone clip
but i i do think that joe rogan goes too
far
here in his comments and i think most of
my audience tends to agree with that
but join the discussion yourself on the
subreddit
by going to davidpakman.com slash
r-e-d-d-i-t it's free
i'm selling you nothing other than a
free good time okay
uh check it out i've been ignoring
this new blog of donald trump's for many
weeks
because he's posting daily trash to it
of no
meaning significance and often even
related to topics that are not remotely
newsworthy it's basically the last gasps
for attention from a guy who is really
desperate for attention
but banned for many social media
platforms but yesterday i came to you
and i said
sirs in my audience the civil
investigation into the trump
organization
being undertaken by the a.g of new york
leticia james
has now become a criminal investigation
that was the news yesterday a major
change there are now
multiple criminal investigations going
on into donald trump's organization
one being done by manhattan d.a sai
vance jr
the other by new york ag leticia james
and my instinct yesterday was
trump's going to go nuts trump's going
to go absolutely
unhinged as a result of this so i went
over
to donald j trump.com desk which is his
blog
and trump put out almost like a full
page of breathless run-on sentences
attacking everyone half the post is in
scare quotes
and you have to see it to believe it i'm
going to
try to read some of it but i can't do
all of it because i'm going to run out
of breath
okay so here is some of what trump wrote
in reaction to now being under
two two criminal probes here we go
buckle up
i have just learned through leaks in the
mainstream media that after being under
investigation from the time i came down
the escalator five and a half years ago
including the fake russia-russia-russia
hoax the two-year 48 million dollar no
collusion molar witch hunt impeachment
hoax number one impeachment hoax number
two and others that the democrat new
york attorney general has informed my
organization that their investigation
is no longer just a civil matter but
also potentially a criminal
investigation working with the manhattan
district attorney's office
that's one sentence my friends okay
trump goes on to say
there is nothing more corrupt than an
investigation that is in desperate
search of a crime but make no mistake
that is exactly what is happening here
the attorney general of new york
literally campaigned on prosecuting
donald trump even before she knew
anything about me
she said that if elected she would use
her office to look into every aspect of
my real estate dealings
she swore that she would definitely sue
me
she boasted on video that she would be
and i quote a real pain in the ass she
declared just wait until i'm in the
attorney general's office and i've got
my eyes on trump tower
she also promised that if elected she
would join with law enforcement and
other attorney generals dude that's
that should be attorneys general across
this nation and removing this
president from office and it's important
that everyone understand that the days
of donald trump are coming to an end
the attorney general made each of these
statements not after having had an
opportunity to actually look at the
facts but before she was even elected
before she had even seen a shred of
evidence
this is something that happens in failed
third world countries but not the united
states
if you can run for a prosecutor's office
pledging to take out your enemies and be
elected to that job bipartisan voters
who wish to enact political retribution
then we are no longer a free
constitutional democracy
likewise the district attorney's office
has been going after me for years based
on a lying discredited low life who was
not listened to or given credibility by
other prosecutorial offices
and sentenced to three years in prison
for lying and other events unrelated to
me
these investigations have also been
going on for years with members and
associates of the trump organization
being viciously attacked harassed and
threatened in order to say anything bad
about the 45th president of the united
states
this would include having to make up
false stories numerous documents all
prepared by large and prestigious
prestigious
law and accounting firms have been
examined and many hours of testimony
have been taken from many people
some of whom i have not seen in years
all right there's there's like pages and
pages and pages and
it ends with if these prosecutors
focused on real issues
crime would be obliterated and new york
would be great
and free again extraordinarily triggered
i mean just completely and totally off
the rails
and just imagine what will happen
if donald trump or more likely
associates or whatever
were to be charged it would be
completely
off the rails and i don't know how
scared trump personally is
but there are a lot of people around
donald trump that are very
very scared right now because of now two
criminal investigations
into the trump organization and so i
don't know how much more we're going to
continue hearing from donald trump we
spoke already about how
uh rudy giuliani has the walls closing
in around him as well
and trump seems to have made the
decision that he wants to head for the
hills
and have nothing to do with defending
rudy or speaking out or helping rudy
raise money or any of it which he has
been asked to do repeatedly
so it's certainly possible that the fear
is actually starting to reach donald
trump at this point in time at the same
time the counterbalance to that is that
people
we've said this before people as
narcissistic as donald trump tend to
think nobody can touch me
and that is something which may keep
trump in a sort of
uh fantasy world where he's not worried
at all now
for his sake it's probably not going to
ever lead
to charges against donald trump as i've
said before and it's certainly not going
to lead to prison time so
maybe trump isn't crazy not to be afraid
if he's not afraid
but triggered he is and i would only
expect as these investigations build
and if rudy giuliani is charged this guy
is going to absolutely explode the likes
of which we have probably not yet seen
we'll have more on this including donald
trump's multi-page single paragraph rant
it's one paragraph but it's many pages
on his blog on the david pakman show
instagram
which you can find at davidpakmanshow on
instagram
at davidpakmanshow on instagram you can
also find me on
instagram not as good as the pakman show
account i try but i'm not nearly as good
at posting
uh david.pacman you can find me on
instagram we are going to speak
to bill share after this brief break and
then i will do my mask rant a little bit
later on in the show
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent better
21.
today we are going to be speaking to
bill share
certainly a familiar face on the show
although in a literal sense
the the the current hairstyle and beard
makes him look a little bit different
than normal
uh bill share is a contributor to the
washington monthly
political magazine and real clear
politics and also also hosts the history
podcast
when america worked uh bill always great
to have you on
do i still hold the record for most
david pak with your appearances or have
i lost that
i think so there was a period where
richard wolff surpassed you
but you've taken it back now i think
which is good which is good
um okay so we've got the 1-6 commission
moving forward but that's not a biden
proposal joe biden has talked about he
has this tax reform plan
he has a jobs plan he has an
infrastructure plan
there are different ideas for how
different of elements would be paid for
and disagreements as to the size of
packages and all of these different
things
if you just look at the rest of this
year do any of those things get done
which is the most likely which is the
the likely to benefit biden the most
politically
well i think biden has made clear
inaction
is not an option in terms of
infrastructure okay i don't think he can
go back to the voters in 2022
and said sorry i got bupkus but i fought
really hard
he needs something uh and what's
interesting
is what's happening with the 1-6
commission
which seems very uh bitter
partisan fractious yes you got 35 house
republicans that came over
but mccarthy was against it mcconnell
came out against it
it seems like it's same old same old
moving farther and farther apart uh
while that's happening biden continues
to
meet with republican leaders on
infrastructure right
and mitch mcconnell of all people
says uh i would i think we can do 600
800 billion dollars now no democrats
aren't necessarily
over the moon about that but it's hardly
the same
as i want to make joe biden a one-term
president i
i'm not going to give him anything for
it for anything uh
there is some and i understand people
can be
mistrustful and cynical about
mcconnell's motives here i don't
i'm not arguing that mcconnell is a
saint
or doing something out of the goodness
of his heart but clearly there is
something there
that he does not want to be seen
as obstructionist on infrastructure
there is a worry on the republicans part
uh and the question is can bayern
exploit that
to get a bill with 60 votes which he may
need to get
if he cannot get 50 for a partisan
reconciliation bill on infrastructure
well now so i guess i'm i'm
i've been thinking about whether the
fear of appearing obstructionist is is
warranted because i mean just to think a
little bit about the 1.9 trillion
covet stimulus under biden where people
got the 1400
um there were two discussions when that
was going on
one will the democrats suffer if they
pass this without republican support
i think the the answer is clearly uh no
people got their 1400 bucks and they're
pleased with that and some even believe
that republicans actually had a role to
play we just looked at a bunch of
polling many of the people who got the
1400 bucks don't know that they got it
only because of democrats
the other side of that was will
republicans suffer in any way
for having not participated at all in a
coveted stimulus bill that was quite
popular with the american people
it seems the answer there is also sort
of no at least as far as i can tell
right now
so what i'm kind of getting to is if
democrats just keep doing stuff on their
own when they can and the things that
require 60 votes obviously though they
can't do that
is there really going to be any
consequence for anybody for democrats
just doing stuff on their own
what what's an unknown here is inflation
uh we don't know what the economy is
going to look like
six months from now one month from now
one year from now
we have these we we have an inflationary
spike
in the past month but which the biden
people say
is temporary the fed thinks it's
temporary the fed thinks it can manage
it it's not going to get
it's not going to go off the rails well
remember i mean it wasn't from march to
april it was april 21 compared to april
20 where there was a complete demand
collapse everything was cheaper than
ever i mean i think it's quite
possible that it's it's an artifact
really well there is all i mean there's
also a month-to-month inflation increase
too
oh that one i haven't seen the bigger
spike is year to year yeah okay
okay but there is a march to april also
i hadn't seen that uh
yeah but i mean it could it could just
be
the weirdness of coming out of a
pandemic that will correct itself
yep or not uh so
i think both parties are kind of
waiting and watching to see who's going
to get the better of that argument
down the road but having said that
you know you're not seeing republicans
say we should not have
any infrastructure bill because we're in
the midst of inflation
and that would just make things worse
yeah because that's a long-term bill
that's for eight to ten years it's not
about today
uh and there are republicans that still
want to bring home some bacon
to their own states and districts so
and and on top of that i think i think i
can't say for as a fact
i think mcconnell wants to be able to
say he did something
he would like to obstruct a lot of other
things but once we were able to say hey
look
i'm a reasonable guy i met them halfway
on physical traditional infrastructure
and that gives me the credibility to
block him on all these other things
uh so if so
they are talking what the two parties
are saying on infrastructure
have overlap there the red lines that
are being drawn do not negate the
possibility of a compromise
and again biden can't come up with
nothing no
joe manchin could say okay forget the
republicans they're not being reasonable
here
uh we tried you you gave your best shot
i'll go with you on reconciliation right
now
he is not there yet and we don't know if
he's ever going to get there so you may
be right in saying hey democrats can do
this politically
without repercussion that's only true if
50 senate democrats agree to do that
yeah she doesn't agree or chris doesn't
agree or what have you then you just
can't do it
and i think as long as republicans are
putting
semi-reasonable proposals on the table i
don't think a joe manchin pulls the plug
on the process and that might require
you to do that kind of deal
one of the changes in the republican
party certainly during the trump era but
in particular in the last four months is
that while
okay mitch mcconnell is going to
meetings and a few republicans are going
to meetings to talk about things
the republican party is not really a
party of policy at this point
in time some members of the house just
straight up say it i mean madison
cawthorne's office has said
we're not a part we're not running a
policy office we're running a
communications office and we're doing
tweets and we're doing memes
and we're doing you know talking about
guns on the house floor on his
wheelchair and all of this different
stuff
at some point will that implode or can
that be viable
when republican voters don't seem to
mind the idea
of just getting in the way of democrats
and not really doing anything
well this is what both the democratic
and republican negotiators have to
consider i mean there's i think
there you look at the majority of the
republican party look at polls you look
at the house caucus
this is you'd say this is a party still
obsessed with trump
cult of personality yeah not interested
in real legislating or governing
just wanting to fight culture war
battles and exploit grievances
and how can you work with that but here
you got liz cheney making the minority
point within the republican party
we have to get back to being a party of
substance and policy we can't sustain
as a cult of personality party i'm not
quoting a verbatim here but i think
that's the gist of what she's saying
well yeah but also i mean i have to say
she voted with trump like 93
of the time the policy she wants to get
back to i don't know it's like
i'm i'm not sure that she's really that
different well though
she liz cheney wants to get back to
hawkish foreign policy
yeah she wants the republican party to
be a neocon party again
yeah that's her okay now
do you have in the senate enough
republicans
who take a longer view say look
we can't survive as a cult of
personality party
that may be fine if you want to hold on
to 200 house seats
but if you actually want to be a
majority again if you look at the
presidency again you want to have a set
of functions again that we have the
upper hand with we have to look beyond
the immediate passions
of our base and we have to show that we
can we can do it
and survive doing it uh this is an
opportunity
for the romneys and the portmans and
the the capitols and perhaps the
mcconnells to say
we can still do this bring home stuff
for our states and our districts
and people will respect this for it and
if so if that sentiment is there
can biden ken schumer ken manchin can
they draw that out
and come up i mean the build that
presumably can get done
is 800 billion traditional
infrastructure
without raising taxes on corporations or
not a lot on corporations
some pills some bitter pills are
democrats to swallow
in that but still something that the
body could go back to the public and say
i did this tangible stuff that we did
delivered for you reward us in 2022 and
2024 for it
there is a potential for common ground
there if both parties see
short-term long-term incentive
for their own parties there is um
i believe no chance that the capital
gains rate
gets increased the way joe biden has
signaled he would want to do
i think it's just one of those things
that in the end isn't going to happen it
seems
very exciting to a lot of people i think
there's a very interesting
budget calculation in terms of what it
would do it would be significant
i see that as an example of something
that is just is
destined to die and it's not happening
am i being unrealistic in my analysis of
that piece
uh not necessarily and look let me try
to let me try to tie a few threads
together
yes so biden has
two big tax proposals connected to
the american jobs plan and the american
families plan
right the american jobs plan which is
mostly traditional infrastructure but
good
goods gets a little non-traditional
long-term care uh school construction
things that
republicans don't count as traditional
um
that's tied to the corporate tax
increases uh
and uh yo joe manchin has said i don't
want to go as far as you do joe biden
i'll meet you halfway there
uh so you already have some indication
that bait doesn't have 50 democrats for
his proposal as is republicans say we
don't want to touch
the trump tax cut at all right we
want to increase user fees uh
maybe increase the gas tax maybe maybe
create a new vehicle mileage tax which
would
hit electric cars and hybrid cars more
we don't want that
what's that i don't want that well you
know it's not
crazy i mean i mean we have functioned
on a user-paced principle
for highways for over 50 years it's not
a new idea the republicans have the only
newness is extending it to hybrid
electric cars right
so again if you're joe biden and getting
a bill is
first and foremost and you can't
get 50 for your ideal tax plan
that makes the republican plan more
relevant in the discussion so
biden may say you know what i don't need
the corporate tax hike here
now so let me add one other element here
what's the other big thing that biden
really needs
he needs to extend that child
tax credit expansion right that is a
signature policy achievement
the monthly checks are going to start
coming in july
but they expire after december if they
run
out you've lost your signature policy
achievement people are going to be mad
hey you gave me these checks and now you
cut me off
uh and this might have to get decided
during an inflationary spike where
people might say hey bud you put too
much money in the system you're over
you're overheating the economy
the only way you can argue you're not
going to overheat is what they pay for
by not having any deficit spending but
having those checks be offset with it
with other tax revenue which some
democrats like angus king who's
independent but caucus with democrats
have already said
i want that paid for you're not
going to get 100 so child tax credit
expansion 100 billion dollars a year
the corporate tax hike plan of violence
is 166 billion a year
and the taxes in the american families
plan which are on wealthy individuals
that's another 100 billion dollars a
year right there's only so many pots of
money here
so if you need a hundred billion dollars
a year
to cover the child tax credit expansion
to extend it beyond 2021
that's probably going to be a
reconciliation bill you're probably not
get republicans to come along
and help save your partisan policy
achievement
so save your partisan tax proposal
for that and work with republicans on
something that's not
as partisan for the infrastructure bill
i think that's where the stars are most
likely to align
the thing i really continue not to
understand about the corporate tax rate
discussion and maybe
this is by design and this is exactly
the theater that that they want
um you know the corporate tax rate being
21 28 or 35
it has a far smaller impact than a lot
of people
believe first of all because it doesn't
apply to sole proprietorships
it doesn't apply to llcs it doesn't
apply to s-corporations all of which are
taxed
as pass-through entities at the personal
income tax rate so then you've got just
the bucket of c
corporations and a few other specific
entities that are subject to the
corporate tax
rate but many of them are paying zero or
nine or eleven or seven percent
anyway because of the extensive
deductions and a lack of a corporate
alternative minimum tax
so i feel like it's a sort of insane
asylum discussion
about mansion thinks this and it was 35
and 28
when it's not really the way that you
capture tax revenue from c
corporations anyway unless you deal with
the other stuff are both sides just
agreeing to pretend that's not an issue
well that's why it's
relatively easy for buyer to say okay
joe manchin i'll come down
to 28 to 25 on the over income tax rate
because the bigger issue are the
loopholes
right how do i make sure they can't
escape paying the rate
at all uh but that's gonna be a very
hard thing to negotiate i think you
could negotiate with joe manchin
by some some middle ground there with
the joe manchin may not be exactly what
buying has right now but you get
something from him
much much harder to get that with
republicans yeah so why
try uh why kill yourself to get 60 votes
on the corporate tax reform which would
probably be very very difficult to be
very very watered down
when you need some big money
for the child tax credit expansion uh
so that's why i think i mean again i i
can't promise this is what's gonna
happen
maybe they go full partisan across the
board
maybe maybe they shoot the moon
completely because republicans are too
uh are too obstructionist i mean i can't
negate that possibility
but so long as republicans are in the
game and so long as matches keeping them
in the game
i think you got to keep in mind that you
got to have a pay for in your back
pocket by the end of the year
especially if inflation is spiking and
you gotta show
that you're paying for your checks
a lot to look forward to i think is the
point and certainly
as we get into 2022 things that i mean
the child tax credit may play
significantly in the 2022 midterm so
these are not
merely academic discussions i think is
fair to say
we've been speaking with bill share
contributor to the washington monthly
politico magazine and real clear
politics and of course host of the
history podcast
when america worked bill always great
having you on
my pleasure talk to you soon the david
pakman show depends on the support of
our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them all right i've got a
message for everybody today
listen very carefully here i don't want
to be misunderstood
i don't care if you want to wear a mask
forever
and what i mean by that is i don't mind
it doesn't bother me it's no skin off my
back it really doesn't bother me at all
i'm not going to think twice if you want
to wear a mask forever or for years
or indoors or outdoors or whatever i
have
no interest whatsoever in telling
anybody
not to wear a mask or worrying about
people who plan to wear masks
even beyond when the cdc recommends it
but
there are increasingly more and more
republicans
who are going off the wall with rage and
fury
that other people want to keep wearing
masks
now this is actually a really big topic
because fundamentally
this relates to the psychology of the
pandemic pandemic induced ptsd
agoraphobia fear adjustment and a whole
bunch of different things that i'm glad
to talk about
in a moment but fundamentally this
reaction from the right is the absurd
hypocrisy of people who constantly claim
for decades they've been claiming we're
about liberty
individual freedoms letting people do
whatever they want as long as it doesn't
infringe on someone else's freedom to do
what they want
they are all about letting others do
whatever the hell they want to do
and they will not stop talking about
others who want to keep wearing masks
of no consequence whatsoever to tucker
carlson
or to whoever doesn't want to wear a
mask
let's look at some examples here is a
recent headline from a fox news uh
tucker carlson interview with brit hume
called quote
some people want to wear their masks
forever it was a segment
dedicated to ridiculing and criticizing
people
who may be vaccinated but want to
continue wearing a mask
here is a segment from fox news where
reporter peter ducey
either feigns confusion uh or is really
confused
about why joe biden wore a mask inside a
ford auto plant earlier this week
despite being vaccinated and despite the
cdc guidelines now saying you know
vaccinated people really don't have to
wear masks in most situations including
indoors
let's take a look at this segment but
the president is saying a lot
by showing us what he's wearing we have
some new video you can see
at a electric vehicle plant in dearborn
michigan he has got a face mask covering
his mouth and nose which conflicts with
the cdc guidance that
you don't have to do that or socially
distance indoors or
outdoors as long as you are vaccinated
which the president has been
since before taking the oath of office
now when it comes to that specific event
with joe biden at the ford plant and i
believe it was michigan
remember that the cdc guidelines are not
state policy
and the cdc guidelines have not yet been
made state policy in many places and
state policy and state law
supersede recommendations from the cdc
at the end of the day they're just
recommendations
and of course ford not just michigan
ford may well still have a policy that
everybody's masking indoors regardless
of vaccination status
many retailers still do etc but
fundamentally
putting that aside who cares if other
people want to wear masks as i've said
before
i don't believe the outdoor masks were
ever really necessary
in almost any situation but i did it in
order to be a team player
because those were the cdc guidelines
and or
state guidelines and as soon as the cdc
said masks are no longer recommended
outdoors for vaccinated people
i haven't worn my mask outdoors since
other than in specific situations like
waiting in line to get into a grocery
store where the grocery store recommends
it
now that the cdc has said basically
every activity for vaccinated people is
low risk
i'm seeing other vaccinated people and
the truth is
everybody i know is vaccinated at this
point but i'm seeing vaccinated people
indoors we're not wearing masks i've
even sat inside of some cafes
but when i see people outside wearing a
mask i don't care i don't give it two
seconds of thought
if i if i devote some thought to it i
might wonder well
maybe they're not yet vaccinated okay so
they're wearing a mask
maybe they have a particular situation
medically
where they are at risk uh or maybe they
just like covering their face or maybe
they're afraid because it's been
14 months of this and it takes time for
people to readjust or whatever
who cares just because it's not the cdc
recommendation and just because i'm not
doing it
what do i care if other people are doing
it as long as they're not
berating me to do something that is not
part of the cdc recommendation so this
is yet another one of those
instances in which the hypocritical
right wingers
claim to have certain values but they
don't stand
by them when the rubber meets the road
now the other reality
we also should mention is that any
guidelines
where there is a degree of nuance
where you need more than one sentence
it's probably too complicated for the
people that
watch fox news so it wouldn't be
surprising to me if the reason
imagine that we looked and like maybe
michigan has pulled the
mask mandate and maybe ford did too i
don't know it looks like everybody was
wearing a mask there so ford probably
requires it but imagine that ford said
you don't have to wear masks if you're
vaccinated michigan said the same thing
if fox news viewers turn on the tv
and absent any context they just see joe
biden walking around with no mask
many of them are going to immediately
take their masks off in all situations
even around vaccinated people because
they don't understand what the hell is
going on so
in some sense you could make the case it
makes a lot of sense for the president
of the u.s
to keep wearing the mask when he's going
to appear on tv and in public
so that unvaccinated fox viewers don't
see it
and assume they're clear to just do
whatever the hell they want
despite not being vaccinated and despite
being indoors around other unvaccinated
people so
first of all i don't care what other
people are doing with their masks
power to them to do whatever they want
but at the same time because we have so
many ignorant people in the united
states
in a way it kind of makes sense that
this is exactly
uh what joe biden would be doing so come
on guys just live your life get yourself
vaccinated follow the cdc guidelines
don't worry about what other people are
doing let them do whatever they want
this is super interesting when the
coveted relief bill passed
uh with joe biden president the 1.9
trillion where we had 1400
checks go out to people you of course
i'm sure remember
that not a single republican elected
official
voted for it i'm not saying almost
no republicans voted for it zero
republican senators voted for it zero
republican members of the house voted
for it
people got coveted cash republicans
democrats
independents apolitical people people
got coveted cash
only because of democrats voting for it
not a single republican voted for voted
for it and we said at the time
is this going to really lead to
consequences for republicans
because there are many republicans who
will get their 1400 bucks
and never find out that no republicans
voted for it
there are many of these republicans who
will get their 1400 bucks
and say well i want the 1400 i like the
1400
i know my republican officials didn't
vote for it but i don't care
because i still got it anyway and i'm
not going to hold them accountable so we
had a
sense that you were not going to see
punishment
for republicans for voting against very
popular
coveted stimulus checks that went out we
now have a new poll
which finds that 50 percent of rural
voters
don't realize that it is only thanks to
democrats
that they received those fourteen
hundred dollar checks um
americans have so far received three
direct payments from the federal
government during the pandemic
two were under donald trump one was
under democrats the first
two under trump's administration had
huge democratic support and it was
thanks to
republicans and democrats that people
got those first two bills
but the third one under joe biden's
watch was only
because of democrats rural objective
pac this is a super pac that is working
to build
democratic support in rural or rural as
some say
areas found that 50 percent of voters
in rural areas associated
the recent coveted stimulus checks with
the democratic party
32 percent believe they got those checks
thanks to republicans
and 11 percent believed that it was not
a partisan thing one way or the other
seven percent weren't sure
so this is a a problem for democrats for
several reasons
number one democrats are failing to
connect with rural voters
since they have half of them have no
idea
that it is because of democrats and
democrats alone that they got those
fourteen hundred dollars
and then the second part the second
problem is
uh it seems as though republicans are
mostly going to get away
scot-free with no or almost
zero consequences for opposing the
coveted stimulus
which was very very popular um
if you're looking for some good news
those same rural voters were asked
that enhanced and extended unemployment
who do you have to thank for that most
of them knew that that did have to do
with democrats now what's weird is it's
all in the same
bill it it's you know
i don't know this is the type of stuff
that people like rachel bittikoffer and
others study and maybe maybe could
explain it to us
um but this does not bode particularly
well for democrats in a number of
different ways and these are really not
matters of opinion i mean there
there is a group in this country that
just has no idea what's going on around
them
there's no other way to say it these are
not matters of opinion
there are you know we've talked before
there are people
who like the affordable care act but
hate obamacare and there are people who
are skeptical of obamacare
but would be okay expanding the
affordable care act and of course it's
the same thing they don't know it's the
same thing
um this is not the the
the we we are not talking about an
opinion
about things we are talking about facts
and a large swath of the population
that is clueless to the facts now some
of them are uninformed
the as the poll said 11 percent
uh uh think that the covet stimulus had
nothing to do with republicans or
democrats
seven percent just weren't sure so some
people are are really
um uninformed some people are
misinformed they believe something that
is absolutely not true
because it's been fed to them in some
way shape or form they've been fed the
same lies for decades
they fall for all of them it's not
surprising and they can't tell
whether something is fact or fiction and
often they can't tell whether a
statement
is a statement of fact or a statement of
opinion
fox news is misinforming them
republicans are misinforming them
trump misinformed them you know sinclair
owned tv stations or misinforming them
and they don't know any better
there's not really any clear way to get
them out of the right wing bubble
they watch right wing tv they listen to
right wing radio they go
on facebook and see things shared by
people who have the exact same beliefs
they go to their church and often get a
lot of the same stuff they have no idea
what is going on and so the question
we're continuing to grapple with
to which i don't have an answer i wish i
wish i did but i don't have an answer
how do you deprogram 75 million
trumpists
how do you do it and we've talked before
about
the retail strategy which is you on a
one-on-one basis
develop a relationship with people over
time and slowly change their views
it can take weeks or months the retail
strategy unfortunately is not likely to
be the nasty programming that we need
what would be a wholesale strategy that
would work i don't know i don't even
know how to break these people out of
their
echo chamber filter bubble so we
continue to search for answers to that
is where we'll leave it today
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p i would love to hear from you
if you have any
message for me hopefully a polite one uh
you can leave it at 219 to david p
here's a great question about something
we we've touched on a little bit before
but it's particularly relevant now
in the conversations about the january 6
riots why are some in the media
referring to these right-wing terrorists
as militia members take a listen
yes i'm just wondering why the media
continues to call
these right-wing terrorist groups
militia
they are actually vigilantes right most
media people are really always
very critical about how they use words
vigilantes are people who
take the law into their own hands and
that's what they're they're not militia
and they want to sound they want to call
themselves militia
just to sound more legitimate of course
this has been something we've talked
about for a long time
many of these groups these sovereign
citizen groups and these anti-government
groups and those who
um those who come out to oppose antifa
sometimes with violence or whatever the
case may be and by the way that's not me
endorsing violence from anybody to be to
be very clear
uh they want to be called militia
militia sounds sort of like an
unofficial
military battalion or platoon or
whatever the case may be
you're talking about vigilantes who are
taking the law into their own hands um
in in violation of the law you're
talking in many cases when they actually
go out and commit
acts of whatever we're talking about
terrorism here and i think the media
corporate media would be much more
accurate if they were using that term
rather than militia at minimum say
self-described militia
uh which is not actually a real thing in
terms of legally binding or
conferring any kind of rights or or
uh privileges to be vigilantes this is
something that they've dubbed themselves
it's extrajudicial
it's not recognized by the law in any
way shape or form
uh it would be great if that was made
more clear on a regular basis
very astutely pointing that out in the
voicemail call
if you have a message for me 2192
david p on the bonus show today the
colonial pipeline ceo
now admits to authorizing a greater than
4
million dollar ransomware payment to get
the pipeline
flowing again incredible chicago mayor
lightfoot says she will only be giving
one-on-one interviews
uh-oh to journalists of color
we will weigh in on that and the
governor of texas greg
abbott has now signed into law one of
the most
restrictive abortion bills in the
country which would ban abortion
as early as six weeks we will talk about
whether that will hold legally and much
much more on today's bonus show
please get access to the bonus show this
is my please clap moment
please get access sign up at
joinpacman.com
make a pledge at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow and then you will be
brought right into the world of the
award-winning
world-famous bonus show i will be joined
by producer pat
and i will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman